did you know that the Transformers
movies are at the point where they're
hiring entire teams of VFX experts just
to create single sequences and that for
some shots they had to create entire
environments down to the smallest detail
just so they can blow them up in the
movie they've been a Marvel of VFX
Wizardry for going on 16 years so let's
take a look at some of these movies with
and without the amazing VFX okay so
director Michael Bay moves fast and
that's a huge understatement we got 150
setups in three days he's known for
being an intense dude and pushing the
actors and the crew to their limits but
part of that could be because Bay knows
how long the VFX is gonna take
Devastator the guy that tears the
pyramid apart took 72 hours of frame to
render so he's got to make sure the
actual filming part moves hella fast so
the VFX team can get to work of course
that doesn't mean Michael Bay can have a
little fun too check out this shot of
him in the passenger seat of a truck as
as it gets run through by a Transformer
we can see him and the driver act out
their reaction on a green screen and
then get added into the exploding truck
speaking of how long VFX takes another
time-consuming aspect of the process is
getting the scale and the scope of these
creatures to fit into the reality of the
movie here is a great sequence showing
how the VFX team from Age of Extinction
put together assets of various sizes
into a shot so that the huge ship would
contrast with the smaller though still
pretty freaking big Transformer and
here's a sequence showing the way they
put together an age of Extinction scene
basically creating a huge room out of
nothing and of course they also added
Transformers into the environment
meaning almost everything you see in the
shot was created by the VFX team and
while that was a more static shot there
are plenty of incredible sequences with
tons of movement here's a breakdown that
shows a Chase between two Transformers
in Dark of the Moon where they not only
fight each other but also as per usual
wreak havoc on the environment around
them in this case it's cool to see how
the VFX team and the producers first
used a real truck smashing into cars on
the freeway then once the aliens were
rendered they replaced the truck so it
looks like the cg'd creatures were the
ones smashing the cars aside it's also
pretty fun to see the vibrant colors
they used during the VFX process to
distinguish between each CG element now
sometimes they actually didn't want us
to see individual characters as in the
case of the mega Transformer Devastator
it was made up of six to eight separate
earth-moving vehicles so they needed to
be able to create those individual
Transformers and then seamlessly
integrate them into one huge creature
first we needed to build all the
vehicles he was constructed out of and
then from all those parts we started to
assemble this massive robot Devastator
interestingly Enough Michael Bay wasn't
happy with the lack of details at first
when the VFX team presented it we had to
go back and almost doubled the model in
terms of complex City it wasn't just the
characters like Devastator who were
Larger than Life the assets and the
memory it took to create them were huge
in the real world they used more memory
and computer space for Revenge of the
Fallen than any other film ilm had ever
made they were so big we used up more
memory and space than any other film in
the history of the company speaking of
sheer magnitude of VFX sequences
starting with the Revenge of the Fallen
they had to hire entire teams just for
certain scenes this was the case with
the aircraft carrier sequence they hired
a squad of VFX experts who only worked
on that sequence and on screen there
were thousands of little people put into
the aircraft carrier demolition sequence
and the VFX team created them from
scratch they also had to think about
everything that would be on the ship and
create those just so they could be blown
up so you have to replicate everything
that would be in the real world just so
you can tear it all to pieces of course
the people in the movies weren't
strictly ones created with CG the movies
are full of actors who have to First Act
in front of a green screen so that the
VFX teams can integrate them into shots
in post here is a great look at the
bridge sequence in Dark of the Moon
where you get to see the entire sequence
take shape first we see how the bridge
was composited from scratch and then how
they started to fill in the background
and the characters it's a really awesome
breakdown of each moment as the actor is
flung from inside the car as it
transforms and then caught by the
Transformer and placed back into the
passenger seat when it transforms back
into a car and of course blowing things
up or smashing them to Smithereens is a
big part of these movies but when you
start to pay attention to the sheer
amount of detail they show in each frame
it's pretty mind-blowing like this
sequence from Dark of the Moon where you
see both outside and inside the office
building as it gets basically Anaconda
to pieces you can see they were paying
attention to each Shard of glass and
piece of the building as well as the
various parts of the Transformer ripping
the building to shreds okay I'm gonna go
drive my car around and see if there are
any buttons that secretly turn it into a
speaking alien slash robot you never
know maybe they hide that button have
any thoughts about the VFX for
Transformers pop them in the comments